hola cómo están
muy bien estoy muy contento de que los
que me conocen de aquí piensan que me
invitaron por ser uno de los más guapos
de la ciudad no es así en realidad soy
un apasionado de la comunicación y de la
educación y hoy quiero platicarles el
tema que escribí para te de c's y que de
corazón creo que es la forma más bonita
de ver la comunicación que es como una
ciencia hoy quiero platicarles de la
solución que olvidamos
hace 100 años los juguetes la ropa de
trabajo y la música eran diferentes
porque eso es tendencia eso cambia con
el tiempo pero se conserva la cultura
nuestro folklore nuestra comida nuestra
vestimenta típica porque eso es cultura
y se mantiene para siempre nos brinda
identidad
cuando se habla de cultura empecé a
pensar un montón cómo abordar la cultura
sin embargo la única forma de abordar la
cultura es pensando en los niños y es
que es un cliché pensar que los niños
son el futuro no los niños son el pasado
el presente y el futuro porque los niños
de hace 30 años son los que están
cometiendo hoy actos tan atroces que
cuesta creer que alguna vez fueron niños
los niños de hace 30 años son las
personas que en este momento les hizo
tanta falta un momento importante en sus
vidas que entendieran la importancia de
la humanidad la importancia de la
integridad los niños son nuestra cultura
entonces cuando se trata de niños la
palabra más importante es aprender
y es que aprender se puede abordar de
muchos lados pero yo amo la comunicación
y uno de los temas más importantes en la
comunicación es el lenguaje que cambia
que crece que se modifica que que se va
aumentando que se agregan palabras
nuevas pero que evoluciona conforme
crecemos tanto diplomática como
profesional y emocionalmente nuestro
lenguaje evoluciona y para aprender
también lo vemos en caminar y en comer
cuando escribí esta charla acaba de dar
una escuela para padres y me pidieron
que diera dos temas primero me dijeron
que el internet de las mamis estaban muy
preocupadas porque el internet no era
seguro que había muchas imágenes que
podrían resultar lascivas para los niños
que eran demasiado explícitas
y claro abordamos el tema de la
importancia que es cuidar a los niños
sobre todo en este entorno digital pero
como bien mencionaba un speaker anterior
el entorno en esta era digital de los
niños es el internet y no puedes privar
a los niños de su entorno porque del
entorno aprenden del entorno es el
primer lugar para aprender para crear
esa iniciativa el despertar es esa
motivación no los podemos pegar de su
entorno y cuando un niño empieza a comer
tira todo de la cuchara cuando un niño
quiere caminar se tropieza pero aprende
y aunque tira todo de la cuchara aprende
a comer y creo de corazón que es ahí
donde fallamos hoy parece normal caminar
hoy parece normal usar la cuchara y
comer porque no parece igual porque nos
parece normal apoyar a alguien más
porque la integridad no es tan normal
como caminar porque como padres como
amigos como hermanos como tíos fallamos
en el momento de enseñar desde niños que
es el proceso cognitivo más importante
fallamos
parte de esta educación un poquito corta
es esta frase que a mí en lo personal no
me gusta mucho porque me la desean
bastante y a lo mejor se lo dijeron en
algún momento típica de las mamis porque
lo digo yo pero por qué por qué lo digo
yo y punto y si lo ves desde el lado
bonito mamá tiene razón mamá te quiere
mamá te ama jamás te va a decir algo que
no sea para tu bien pero cuando no
brindamos explicaciones no fomentamos la
creación de un criterio en el niño y la
frase porque lo digo yo se puede
entender cuando eres un niño porque sí
porque yo mando y cuando está en una
situación que tú no puedas controlar
como la escuela como la primaria va a
haber un niño que sea más alto que sea
más fuerte que seamos popular iba a
tener la situación de poder iba a decir
vamos a ensuciar el uniforme vamos a
ensuciar la mochila y lo va a ser por
qué por qué lo dice él sin preguntar sin
analizar por eso es importante crear
criterio en nuestros niños
cuando se trata de criterio y
investigando mucho me parece una
curiosidad grandota esto leyó en un
libro que decía es que es fundamental
que se realice esta tarea es que es
elemental que se realice esta tarea pero
nuestro idioma es maravilloso porque
cada palabra significa algo distinto
fundamento son los bloques imagínate qué
quieres la casa más bonita del mundo
buscas el mejor blog la mejor varilla la
mejor pintura las mejores ventanas pero
si el terreno donde la vas a hacer son
arenas movedizas pues no tiene ningún
sentido
y pensando ahora en los niños los
elementos son los bloques son los legos
con los que construyen pero si tienen
muchos legos necesitan una mesa más
el fundamento es la mesa los elementos
son todas aquellas cosas de educación
que construimos por eso hay
profesionales que se gradúan de las
mejores universidades que hablan muchos
idiomas elementos que tienen puestos en
empresas increíbles elementos pero
cuando llega el momento de valor el
fundamento
se corrompe
y se corrompen porque tienen muchos
elementos pero el fundamento no es
sólido
cuando se trata de fundamentos mi forma
más sencilla de explicarlo es con la
idea de la sombrilla cuando las mamis me
decían es que voy a ir hay muchas
imágenes que atentan contra la inocencia
de nuestros niños y yo les explicaba que
querer permear los de todo es intentar
llevar una sombrilla
que no te caiga ni una gota pero si
tienes dos hijos hay quien no te caiga
no pero a ti y luego llegan a la escuela
y a la escuela ya no puedes pasar
qué es lo más sencillo enseñarles a que
carguen la sombrilla protegerlos es
indispensable sí pero también tienes que
enseñarles para que se protejan como con
la formación de criterio como explicando
las razones que las órdenes órdenes no
son órdenes y ya es importante proteger
pero es importante enseñar
bueno ya ir pero me estás diciendo que
un montón de problemas problema por aquí
problema por acá todo es un problema
cuál es esa solución entonces
cuando di mi primera escuela para padres
yo tenía un miedo gigante gigante me
temblaban las piernas por una simple y
sencilla razón
yo no soy papá sé que muchos de ustedes
ya se emocionaron no no estoy casado
y tampoco tengo hijos y yo tenía un
miedo gigante porque cuando yo iba a
entrar ese salón con un montón de papas
lo único que yo pensaba es están
pensando todos y este que viene a hablar
a una escuela para padres si no es padre
si no tiene hijos
y la maestra que me invitó me dijo algo
muy sencillo a ver qué estudias la
comunicación la mejor carrera del mundo
estos son ingenieros de esta
comunicación y me dijo la persona que te
da periodismo es comunicólogo
no eres periodista y el que te da cine
es comunicólogo no estudió cine y el que
te da economía y el de gaulle ya entendí
y entendí y me dijo así es ser papá ya
cuando eres papá de golpe tienes que ser
chef tienes que ser psicólogo tienes que
ser un superhéroe y todo en un momento y
nadie te enseña y una cosa que necesitas
cuando eres papá es comunicación así que
tú párate enfrente y hablarles sobre lo
que más amas en el mundo que es la
comunicación y eso es lo que hago en
este momento pararme frente a ustedes
representando a una de las ciudades más
hermosas del mundo porque yo lo creo que
spots acuáticos y tengo la certeza de
decirles estoy convencido que educar con
comunicación social es la comunicación
ideal es la llave que olvidamos cuando
un niño entra primero de primaria les
enseñan verbo sujeto sustantivo
predicado complemento pero no necesitas
saber todo eso para decir te quiero agua
necesito ir al baño me pica
y están usando verbo sujeto predicado
están usando todo
porque el lenguaje nosotros lo enseñamos
la estructura pero a hablar se copia
así pasa con los valores los valores se
copian entre los 0 y 3 años
la etapa cognitiva esponja del niño es
enorme lo aprenden todo y de los 3 a los
6 forman nuestros principios de carácter
es una etapa meta cognitiva entonces si
yo le digo a mi niño respeta a tus
mayores por favor pero ve que papá le
pega mamá
pero vi que mamá está harta de papá que
tiene miedo cuando llega a la casa y ve
que mamá y papá y la otra hermana hablan
mal de la tía está gorda
como puede replicar el conocimiento como
puedes replicar una conducta en la etapa
más más de mayor aprendizaje de toda su
vida si no lo ve
tiene que verlo no se trata solo de
decirlo no se trata solo de explicarlo
lo puede aprender más adelante sí pero
así como con el lenguaje tiene que nacer
desde adentro por eso se llama lengua
madre deben ser valores madre que surjan
desde niños
cuál es la solución para mí es muy
sencilla de los siete días que tiene la
semana por lo menos tres pero me está lo
a su agenda apúntelo de esos 15 minutos
no le pido dos horas 15 minutos siéntese
con su niño y pregúntele cuando fuimos a
la escuela que viste por la calle
bueno había gente que no había comido
que estaba bien sucia la ciudad
crees que podamos hacer para
solucionarlo
podemos hacer tortas quitársela a la
gente podemos ir a limpiar la playa me
dijo mi sobrina
esas no son soluciones que te cambien
todo pero así como con el lenguaje esas
soluciones de niños crecen esos son
elementos y le estás dando fundamentos
y cómo evolucionan sus lenguajes sus
palabras así de forma inteligente van a
solucionar van a crecer sus soluciones
tienen que verte si les das una mayor
cantidad de bloques si les das una mayor
calidad de maestros de escuelas tienes
que darle un fundamento más grande
por lo menos tres días quince minutos
cada día que él proponga una solución
que nazca de él
y háganlo
cuesta dinero esfuerzo puede resultar
que no tengamos todo el día libre pero
hay que intentarlo en un momento como
este de la ciudad hay que intentarlo
la segunda cosa que me pidieron que
diera en la escuela para padres era
vamos a rezar tantito
debo darle todos mis hijos
y ayer a una pregunta difícil busqué por
todos lados y todo el mundo decía no es
peligroso darle todos tus hijos ahí es
muy muy peligroso
pero yo les propongo algo diferente
hay que dárselos
si toda tu vida trabajaste para tener
dinero si toda tu vida trabajaste para
inculcar valores si toda tu vida has
trabajado por tener algo increíble en la
vida y llega a la persona a la que más
amas en todo el mundo dáselo porque es
fruto de tu esfuerzo pero esos que son
bloques son elementos y si le das muchos
elementos que tiene que ser más grande
el fundamento y el fundamento eres tú
eres papá es abuelita eres tío heres
primo el fundamento eres tú la persona
de la que va a copiar todo lo que haces
esas malas palabras esas malas
costumbres o las cosas buenas eres tú y
eso se llama congruencia no basta con
llegar y decirles tienes que hacer esto
creerte tiene que verte en ti dales todo
pero recuerda que el fundamento eres tú
y si le das muchas cosas tienes que
crear un fundamento más grande
que te vea
el entienda que tú como profesional que
tú como papá todo lo que eres todo lo
que haces y todo lo que tienes sirve
para brindar una solución a un problema
social
así va a ser la única forma de que para
el solucionar algo que ve mal en nuestra
ciudad en el país les sea tan normal
como hablar como caminar el fundamento
eres tú que te ve a respetar a una mujer
que te voy a respetar a un hombre a una
persona que te vea porque es la única
forma de que va a poder crear en sí un
lenguaje interno de congruencia criterio
cuando me paré aquí enfrente
estaba muy nervioso todavía sigo muy
nervioso
pero muchas veces menosprecian la
carrera más bonita del mundo que es la
comunicación
vemos momentos difíciles
donde la tecnología ha avanzado
increíble pero esto no se soluciona
donde la medicina ha avanzado de manera
porque esto es cultura y se soluciona
con comunicación y con educación resumen
las cosas no se solucionan con tendencia
se solucionan creando cultura y la
creación de cultura viene con darles
elementos pero con un gran fundamento y
el fundamento eres tú
tiene que verte
respetar que todo lo que eres que todo
lo que haces y que todo lo que tienes
sirve para ayudar a alguien más
y en ese momento nuestros niños quizá en
30 años más
solucionar algo de la sociedad de
nuestra ciudad les sea tan normal como
hablar como caminar y como comer
entonces todo habrá valido la pena
la solución que olvidamos es educar con
comunicación social
esa es la solución que olvidamos en este
momento que tanto hace falta que no se
nos olvide nunca más muchas gracias
[Aplausos]